There is this word
that you might have heard
a lot recently, like right now:
metaverse.
It's suddenly a huge thing.
And while for many people,
it causes a lot of excitement,
I think it also causes other feelings,
like confusion and concern.
And I think that's fair.
And I’ve also felt confused.
Metaverse is not really a new thing.
Many massively multiplayer online games,
for example, can be seen as metaverses.
And I've certainly also felt concerned,
especially when people talk
about "the metaverse."
That assumes that there's only
one owner of the metaverse,
and this owner would get
far too much power and data.
It also risks being exclusive.
It might not be accessible for everyone,
and will risk to introduce
many of the inequities
we see in the real world in the metaverse.
This was pretty sad to me.
So then you might wonder like,
why am I here talking about the metaverse?
That doesn't make sense.
Well, the thing is, I'm not.
I'm here to talk about metaverses
and the vision of how they can provide
a lot of delight to their communities
and even make the real world
a better place.
And here we can learn a lot from games.
So what is even a metaverse?
How do we create a delightful,
long-lasting metaverses?
And how can metaverses
make the real world a better place?
And there are, of course,
many answers to these questions,
and I cannot give you the answer,
but I can give you one answer.
If, instead of talking
about the metaverse,
we talked about thousands
or millions of metaverses
created by people
from all around the world,
it would be much more inclusive
and less risk of toxic uses.
To me, that sounds quite lovely.
What I'm showing you right now
are persistent, endless virtual worlds
where players can have
lots of fun together.
They are worlds that connect people.
Each of these worlds were made
by individuals in Minecraft.
By removing and placing
their own virtual building blocks,
They could create anything
they can imagine.
And to me, these are creative
and delightful examples of metaverses.
And I know the power
and the beauty of these worlds
because I have my own
that's more than ten years old.
This is my world.
After many years of playing,
developing, thinking
and even dreaming about Minecraft,
I have gained some
experience and learnings.
Watching our community use the game
in so many different ways
made me realize how powerful
metaverses can be.
So I would love to, with these learnings,
paint a different picture
of what metaverses can be
if everyone could craft your own.
And I hope it's a creative,
fun and inclusive picture.
In Minecraft, this is one example of this.
We give the players tools
and endless worlds
and an infinite amount of building blocks
to have fun and tinker with.
And with these, the players can craft
their own unique metaverses.
The metaverses, therefore,
belong to the players.
They do not belong to us, making the game.
And like, ah, it’s so fascinating,
because the players are so very,
very creative with the metaverses.
Some use them to be like,
big cities, castles,
or like my five-year-old
daughter's recent project,
an underwater playground for fishes.
And some players are engineers and build
the most complex machines.
It's very, very impressive.
And some prefer to just have
a lovely time with their friends.
The possibilities are endless,
and it's up to each player
to set their own goals
and decide if they want
to create their own metaverse
or join someone else's.
And it's easier to be creative and connect
with people when you have fun.
Fun is important.
And what's more fun than games?
Within games, we've actually
had metaverses for a really long time.
Long-lasting games like World of Warcraft
or Eve Online could be seen as metaverses.
And this doesn't surprise me,
because when we humans
spend time together,
we want to do it in a fun and joyful way.
And this is true when we spend
time together virtually too.
Fun means different things
for different individuals.
Maybe not all of you
want to build fish playgrounds,
even though that clearly is very fun.
But this is another reason to why
there should be many different metaverses.
My dream is that there will be a huge
and diverse set of metaverses.
Having millions of metaverses
with different strengths and focuses
enables everyone to find
virtual places they love,
feel welcome in
and just can have so much fun in.
We live in a time where almost everything
seems to depend on statistics,
metrics and diagrams,
and we can for sure learn a lot from this.
But I feel there is a risk
we forget the pure human side,
the things that excite us,
the things that make us passionate.
I don't think Tolkien used
metrics and stats
when he wrote "Lord of the Rings."
He crafted a universe based on passion,
vision and delighting his readers.
And that’s what metaverse
developers shoul do too.
We should bring smiles to our place.
We should develop features
to give this excited,
butterfly-in-the-stomach feeling.
And I hope this is the case
for anyone building metaverses.
But I must confess, I am a bit worried
that the main question people will ask
when they build future metaverses will be,
"How can we profit from this?"
That's the wrong question.
Instead, we should ask
how will our metaverses benefit the users.
And of course,
I know that money is important
in this real world we live in.
But the thing is, if players
are super happy long-term,
that's very likely also related to money.
So everyone can be happy.
We must focus on taking care
of our communities
instead of taking from our communities.
And that goes hand-in-hand
with player trust and thinking long-term.
Because if you know
that you can trust that your beloved
metaverse will be around
and be very much alive for a lifetime,
you feel safe to spend all this time
and all this love on it.
Look at this amazing world.
It started as a small family project,
and now, ten years later,
the family still plays
together in this world.
I think this is a great example
of why you should be able to trust
that your metaverse will be around
and work very well for a lifetime.
It would be devastating for this family
if they lost this project
they have together
and all the dreams
they still hope to fulfill
in this creative metaverse of theirs.
As metaverse developers,
we have a responsibility to keep
people's memories and dreams safe.
And there's one more thing.
The virtual worlds
can't reach their full potential
on making the real world a better place
if they don't represent
and include everyone.
Also, everyone deserves
the joy and inspiration
a lovely designed metaverse can give.
Therefore, there need to be metaverses
available and accessible for everyone.
Each person that wants to,
I will not force anyone,
should be able to craft
the metaverse of their dreams
independent of their situation
in the real world.
The in-metaverse economy
should not mirror the inequities
we see in the real world.
And it’s much more
delightful and inclusive
if the resources in the metaverse
are part of a fun and fair game system
instead of a system
introducing artificial scarcity.
We also need a variety of metaverses,
including ones that don't require
expensive devices.
So when we then have all these, like,
beautifully designed
metaverses for everyone,
I mean, on top of all
the joy they will bring,
we also get many more opportunities
on making the real world a better place.
And I have seen so many beautiful examples
of how people do that
with their metaverses.
One that's very dear to me
is the dad who created a minecraft server
to be a safe and welcoming place
for his son and other children
on the autism spectrum.
This kind of community-created world
is a great role model
for future metaverses.
It's a world that welcomes players
that maybe don't always feel welcome
in the real world,
and it's a world
that enables these players
to express themselves in their own ways.
Family members have witnessed
how these amazing children
use communication skills
they learned in the metaverse
in the real world.
And metaverses can help
charities reach new audiences
and make it more fun and easy
to participate in charity events.
The World of Warcraft
community, for example,
raised more than one million dollars
[for] Doctors Without Borders
to be able to make a difference
in the global response to COVID-19.
In the metaverses,
charities can meet people where they are.
And metaverses can help us communicate
in a common language,
a language of play, creativity and fun.
There is an organization
called Games for Peace
that uses games and their metaverses
as a neutral playground
to create dialogue,
friendships and trust between
young people in conflict zones.
It wouldn’t even be possible
to bring these young people together
if not for a metaverse they can meet in.
And metaverses can help amplify voices.
Kids in Kosovo used the metaverse
to build their dream neighborhood area.
By giving the kids millions
of virtual building blocks
and endless space to build
and collaborate in,
they could explore and visualize
their ideas in a fun and accessible way.
Young people aren't typically
involved in planning spaces,
but this time it was the kids
who were the experts.
Just imagine all the joy, confidence
and creative ideas that leads to.
And the very lovely thing here
is that their vision was built
in the real world.
Their ideas from the metaverse
became a safe and open meeting area
in their neighborhood.
(Applause)
One of the kids summarized the joy
and confidence this brought
in such a lovely way when she said,
"Being heard and listened to
is one of the best feelings you can feel."
Anytime we can include
new voices in processes
where they have typically been left out,
we shift dynamics, which ultimately
builds a better world.
If we, in the future, have even more
metaverses on different platforms,
beautiful examples like these ones
can happen even more.
I hope and believe that these learnings
from the game industry
and from the metaverses
the communities created
truly can help us all
make better metaverses in the future.
A challenge for all of us
that will design and build metaverses
is to ensure that we use them
for creativity,
fun, inclusivity,
and ultimately to build
a better real world.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)